the whole scenario Jordan woods happened
how do you cope with something like that
where do you find that strength to cope
with difficult things well I think first
of all I pray about it I really do I
find that you know just the spiritual
side of me has to kick in because
otherwise you know I feel like it
wouldn't survive Kris Jenner speaking
out for the first time about the Tristan
Thompson at Jordan Woods drama the pair
allegedly hooked up back in February do
you feel as though you are the reason
why ersten and Chloe are not together I
know I'm not the reason that Tristan and
Chloe are not together now this
situation may have made it harder for
her to want to be with him right and I
understand that but I know I'm not the
reason if I'm just going to ask you
straight up okay
did you sleep with Tristan never the
whole thing is of course awkward for the
kardashian-jenner seeing as Tristan was
Chloe's boyfriend and is the father of
her child while Jordan was Kylie's
bestie the family has seemingly
excommunicated Jordan for the time being
I think that my kids make really good
decisions and I think they try to be as
challenging if some of these situations
are I think that because they have one
another and they try to make a really
good decision that they're going to come
out the other side with a lot of clarity
and a lot of honesty and do what they
feel like is the right thing and I
really trust all of my kids to make
those good decisions you know Chris
opened up on Ryan Seacrest's radio show
remember he's an executive producer on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
[Music]
be so public I'm not just a TV show like
this is my life keeping up is back for
its sixteenth season on Sunday and
judging by the promos we'll get to see
everything a play out we film everything
and we try to show as much as we can in
44 minutes once a week kind of when a
horse show so we try to get in there as
much as we can that we know that
everybody will love and it's just so
good we just can't seem to catch a break
[Music]